Hello everyone, it's Logan Marmino.
-This is...
-Peyton Jackson.
And I play Kyle, Logan's best friend.
It makes me feel so much better
walking with the mayor of middle school.
Oh, kids don't really call me
by that nickname that much.
It's more like a... informal title.
Hi, I am Roger Dale Floyd,
and I play the role of Matthew Dubin.
I'm here. Now the fun can start!
We just joke around.
-Dancing.
Lot of ridiculous stuff.
-And this is...
-Trinity Bliss.
-And she plays Gabriella.
-Gabriella.
Gabriella Decker?
Josh Dubin.
How do you know who I am?
I memorized the yearbook.
Okay.
Today we are filming
a scene from "Field Day."
And I get to incapacitate them
with dodgeballs.
Seriously?
-You haven't hurt yourself yet, have you?
-No.
But the day is still young,
and full of possibilities.
Do you guys remember
the Halloween episode?
Some of those costumes were awesome.
Oh, yeah, do you guys remember
the moon costume?
Golf ball with a face.
Is he serious?
I am the moon from the classic 1902 film
"A Trip to the Moon."
And you expected us to know that?
My mummy costume.
They had to wrap this
big piece of clothing in toilet paper.
He was, like, in the walkie-talkie,
he was, like,
"Roger on the move. Roger on the move.
We cannot get him on the move.
It's gonna rip. It's gonna rip."
Gabriella had two costumes.
She had her fun Sriracha bottle costume
and she had her cute volleyball,
fit in with my friends,
like, red t-shirt, red skirt,
that said "Hot Sauce."
You can tell which one I like better.
Ah, they're ready for us. See you later!
-Bye!
-See ya.
So Logan, tell us about where we are.
We're at the school!
How's this compare to
your guys' real school?
-I'm home schooled, so...
-Same.
A lot bigger than my house.
Do you guys feel like
you relate to the Dubins?
As a home school family?
-Yes.
-Well, yeah.
Public school's going to be
challenging for you
in ways you can't even imagine.
Then maybe I need
to find that out for myself.
Yeah, okay.
-We're going to public school!
This show has just been
so much fun for me to work on.
I just love the cast and crew.
Everyone on this show is so brilliant.
When I go home every night,
I just feel such a happiness in my heart.
This show is just so awesome,
and the number one reason
I wanted to be a part of this
is to spread awareness for amputees,
and for people that are not amputees,
to get to know that
we're really no different than them.
Josh, you don't have to be so brave.
I just don't want any special treatment.
I wanna be treated like everybody else.
Josh, Josh.
You're being rude to the principal.
If anybody treats you any different
because of your leg,
you come talk to me.
People never get the irony.
This whole entire story is just amazing.
It's been amazing
to be a part of this cast, honestly.
-Love you guys. Group hug.
-Yeah...
All right, back to set. Bye guys!
-Back to set!
-Bye!
That was awesome!